our asian community demanding justice  this morning after a woman allegedly hit  a six-year-old asian boy  on the las vegas strip this happened  last week at the shops at the crystals  there near  the aria metro police arrested that  woman there shelly ann hill  days after this video went online an  arrest report claims that  she hill told the child's family the  coronavirus was their fault  the attack caught on surveillance video  as well now hate crimes against the  asian population have risen in the u.s  but they're  relatively low here in nevada still  leaders of our asian community say this  case is different  i think it's about time that we really  hold people accountable for their  actions  i think that's what will change hill the  woman there  scheduled to be back in court july 27th  she faces hate crime and battery charges